the Duke circle is full of clever
bastards but no one is like Jed - his
home is supposed to be full of Marvel's
and there's a reason people are afraid
of his mansion Jin - won't care who you
are what you want he looks at you like
you're a puzzle to be taken apart
take on the next one I'll prove you
wrong
must still be Ron show yourself we're
all we what the mansion has a strange
beauty to it but all such places must
eventually come to ruin
who would build something like this and
why
ah that was activated one of the
mechanisms in my house
she welcome in my home is always open
it's one of my great curiosity is see
how the common mind is navigating I'm
caring in - but you must know that I
invite you to continue stranger just
come upstairs meet with me face to face
the alcohol that is almost there come
into the gallery so I can see in heart I
made this place of luxury and spectacle
I suppose will adorn last this place the
testament to engineering itself
before you stands an invention that was
beyond my time the Jean - clockwork
soldier my greatest speech there you are
magnificent
now that I see you I worked out who are
not a hired cutthroat - your clothes are
too fine an aristocratic thrill-seeker
that's closer you trained with weapons
formerly we do not Aslam fencers could
pack aliens all that and you have the
father's eyes your Imperial Majesty
welcome lady emily kaldwin impressive
gin - then you must also know why I'm
here I assume my involvement with the
Duke brought you to my door or maybe
your after washed up anton sokolov
comfortably residing in the assessment
chamber Iowa combined me into whatever
it is you seek but if you fall I'll have
no part in carry to my lab for
dissection and
funny and since engine dashi until then
clapper soldiers as an interloper in my
home
combat each attached for the clockwork
soldiers each make them better
Laurie long unauthorized present
okay
you won't get away got you very
impressively sound ah the space behind
the wall damn it back to diagnostic
playback loop bill island all unlinked
everything has a purpose it's all
connected Missy one of the finest views
in all car knocker
that's a long way down
Caryn Jenn - well well someone's been
tampering here
there's another choice here with this
machine maybe you won't have to die
after all Jin dosh not sure I'd call it
mercy they bet for detection
lay back
i with the credit profile
now that protocol cake
they took what was mine
I'm going to get it back even if I have
to burn this city to the ground